now this is tough because you're a
humble guy uh but objectively speaking
can you say what your strengths are
you're often listed as one of not the
greatest player of all time so what what
are the things that make you stand out
so for me when I grew up I admired the
big cash game players because that's
what I was I love tournaments but I
wanted to be well-rounded like in my day
you couldn't make the poker Hall of Fame
if you just played one game you had to
jump into the high stakes games in
Bobby's room as they say right and I was
able to do that when I was in my early
in my mid-20s I was playing four
thousand eight thousand limits you know
you could win or lose a million dollars
in a day so I grinded it out like a lot
of people think oh you know he's lucky
he's had sponsorship otherwise he'd be
broke he's like I built multi-million
dollar bankrolls before any of that
stuff existed and I did it the good
old-fashioned way by sitting my butt on
the table I think probably one of my
biggest strengths is self-awareness and
um in that regard a level of humility
that always allows me to say okay well
you know what in this case with these
players they're better than me so what
am I going to learn from them right
rather than have this need to say I'm
the best because of history and I'm
always looking to guys and go wow he
does this really well whether it's the
adamos or the IVs or whoever it may be
um so my willingness to adapt I think
and stay relevant by learning what the
young guys are learning is something
I've always done and I also pride myself
on um again being well-rounded like
playing all the games like I don't feel
intimidated in any game you know
whatever the format is so always being a
scholar of the game as as the game
evolves as the different games of all
the different players of all the culture
evolves always adjusting by being a
scholar having the humility healthy
respect for a healthy respect for the
younger generation how they learn what
they learn and what they can teach me
rather than poo poo it and say oh these
kids today because that's what a lot of
people like the Mike matisos and the
philhealth music My Generation they just
poo poo it because they don't understand
it on a level of one to ten their level
of understanding this is like a one
maybe if I'm being generous by calling
it a one they really don't understand it
so they poo poo it right it's easy to do
that like oh that's not how I do it so
that's wrong or that's stupid or
whatever I don't take that approach I go
well let me learn let me see what what
what there is to this but that said the
crankiness that mattersau and Phil
Hellmuth have is is great to watch
especially when they're on a table with
you and yeah oh I love it yeah it's a
black and black you're masterful of
being able to get under their skin